we're learning new details about the
investigation into last month's deadly
assault on the u.s
capitol the evidence this morning
suggests there were multiple failures to
prepare
and failures to communicate among law
enforcement despite warnings
that an attack was imminent yesterday we
also heard powerful testimony from some
of the police commanders about what they
endured on that terrible day
nicole killian is on capitol hill for us
nicole good morning to you
good morning tony most of the officials
who testified yesterday have since
resigned in the wake of the insurrection
they all
agree this was a well coordinated attack
but one they
didn't see coming these criminals came
prepared for war
in the first hearing into the january
sixth attack former capitol police chief
steven's son said he was
unaware of an fbi bulletin released the
day before
warning violent extremists could descend
on the capitol
you hadn't seen it yourself no ma'am
that raw intelligence came from a
norfolk virginia field office
acting d.c police chief robert congi
says it was sent by email
i would certainly think that something
as violent as an insurrection of the
capitol
would warrant you know a phone call or
something
an fbi spokesperson said the agency
passed on the intelligence within 40
minutes of receiving it
and posted it on a portal available to
law enforcement officers
nationwide cbs news senior national
security analyst fran townsend
says the fbi had an obligation to make
sure the capitol police were aware of
the threat
i think there's a real question not just
their failure to pass the report in the
right way
but why didn't they have it sooner why
didn't they why wasn't that collected
earlier
do you think it could have made a
difference
i absolutely do the capitol hill police
would have had a stronger argument when
they asked for the national guard
sund claimed he was initially denied
national guard troops because optics
were a concern
the former house sergeant of arms
disputed that townsen a former homeland
security adviser says
more resources are needed for capitol
police and that different agencies need
to prepare together
i do think what we've found in a post-9
11 world
is exercises really matter where you
actually go through a scenario with the
interagency so
i think you've got to now look at all
the potential federal targets
and do exercises so everyone understands
what their responsibility is
another hearing will be held next week
with pentagon officials to dive deeper
into some of those national guard delays
and this afternoon
lawmakers will be briefed on the latest
security measures by the acting chief
of capitol police anthony all right
nicole thank you